*pure blackness*
*glass shatters*
*Stone Cold Steve Austin's Theme song*
Some haters say
*Stone Cold Steve Austin's Theme song continues*
I'm not good at games
*more Stone Cold Steve Austin's Theme song*
And to that I say
*Stone Cold Steve Austin's Theme song*
I am the strongest video game player on the planet
I have never died a single time in any video game
FALLEN ONE
I AM SATAN
I AM YOUR GOD NOW
I am - this is being livestreamed right now.
I am calling you..my bros
Ya'll find me on the map
Kill yourself.
For me.
And then make my dick - re - my snake grow
*conquering music to show that poods will beat Slither.io into submission*
I will not die a single time
Alright bros, find senpai and kill yourself already.
God damn it.
OHH!
You just got shit on, ya fucking bitch!
You thought you could kill senpai?
SENPAI NEVER DIES.
People come from various places of the Earth
To watch me play this live.
You want some?
Look at this horny bastard, he want me.
Onii-chan needs some fucking support.
YOU FUCKING ASSHOLE!
YOU THOUGHT YOU COULD PULL A FAST ONE ON ME!
ZERO DEATHS!!
I'm the fastest snake in the universe
'Poods eat me!'
Come on!
There you go!
There you go! (2x)
THEERE YOU GO (3x)
Bru-
I noticed you!
SENPAI HAS NOTICED YOU!
Yes, bros! Its working!
YEEESS!
*singing* I need you now
You take away the biiggest paart of meee
OoOOOooooh >~<
I suck your snaake~
I sucked your snake up~
MY SWEET CHILDREN.
I WILL EAT YOU ALL!
0 deaths!
'For poods'
That's it. You gotta keep growing though.
You're-you're-
You're a tiny micropenis
right now
Holy shit - ya'll are following me, aren't chu?
It gets - "Its just a prank, bro."
*laugh*
Oh god, this is getting so intense.
MOREE!
MOREEE! (2x)
MOREEEE! (3x)
MOREEEEE (4x)
YEAH!
UUUGH
TASTES
GOOOD
Yeaah...
Oh..
More..
More pow-
*I'm Not Okay (I Promise) plays*
*sad piano*
*violin joins*
*more depressing piano*
*le violin*
*piano cries*
The fuck was dat?
*le piano*
You think this is some kind of game?
*le snort*
*more sad music*
ZERO DEATHS!!!!!!!
NO ONE FUCKS PEWDIEPIE.
Hey Nick
Why don't you suck my Nick, dick?
Bitch
Fuck you Nick
*sadly, there is more music..*
That does not count.
ZERO.
DEATHS.
What's good?
What's good ayy lamo?
Ayy lamo.
Ayy lamo (2x)
Suck my lamo.
Bitch.
OH!
You just got fucked!
Oh my gawd
*Sanic theme plays*
Oh my gawd a fuckin gold mine
OH MY GAWD
I AM THE BIGGEST FUCKIN SNAKE IN THE FUCKIN GALAXY
*Sanic-running-like-a-beast music*
That's it.
*le swedish swearwords* = NO BUT IN THE HELL FUCKING PUSSY!!...
tttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttttt
Yes.
Yes. (2x)
Yes. (3x)
My sweet child.
YES
MY SWEET CHILD
*kiss kiss*
PEWDS YAS
Thank you.
Listen, you have to die.
Ya'll have to die.
You know that, right?
'Pewdiepie say: hagelslag'
HAGELSLAG
HAGELSLAG! (2x)
Helvete!
Jävla!
Fitta!
*pewds kicks squeaky toy violently*
What the fuck was that!?
Thats it.
Thats it (2x)
Thats it. (3x)
Thats it. (4x)
Fabulous.
Fabulous. (2x)
Fabulous. (3x)
Fa-
'Pewdiepie'
Pewdiepie, follow me, Pewdiepie!
*kiss kiss kiss kiss*
Come here Pewdiepie.
*kiss kiss kiss kiss, I love you.
YES. I LOVE YOU.
I LOVE YOUU
WE GOT THIS!
WE GOT THIS!!
Oh- oh jävlar
Fuck, it's so tight in here.
Its so fuckin tight.
*Ghostbusters theme plays*
We're not some casual fuckin channel.
That's like: Ehehe
Yeah, I died a couple of times but I didn't really do anything.
Fuck that
Alright. We're going for #1.
*Ghostbusters theme continues*
SUCK MY DICK!
What the fuck was that? That was just fucking lag.
*GHOSTBUSTERS*
Fucking hell
*MORE GHOSTBUSTERS*
*Ghostbusters in a slightly drained down tone*
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT?
IT DIDN'T EVEN FUCKING TURN!
I HATE THIS GAME!
I HATE EVERYONE
..YOU
AND FUCK ME.
GOD.
FUCKING.
DAMMIT